permettre à un tour en jeu de traverser
la ville du nord au sud en une vingtaine
de minutes tel est l'objectif du projet
tramway cher au cœur du maire sortant
Jean Germain un tramway qui aurait pour
vocation de faciliter le quotidien des
habitants et des touristes il y a 55 000
personnes qui chaque jour font des
navettes entre le Nord le Sud le Centre
et le Sud le centre et le nord et donc
on peut plus avoir ce nombre de voitures
qui fasse les jonctions entre Saint-Cyr
tours Tours Centre jouet Tours Centre
donc il faut se tramway qui seul nous
permettra d'avoir le débit suffisant et
puis surtout la qualité environnementale
un projet intéressant mais peut-être mal
conçu selon Renault de nos dieux de
Vabre candidat UMP réévalué le tracé
étudier les alternatives pour mieux
desservir les quartiers et les centres
hospitaliers pour lui le dossier est à
revoir
je suis pour l'utilisation des voies de
la SNCF et avec un meilleur cadencement
pour que toutes les communes de
l'agglomération soient réunies je suis
pour la desserte de tous les quartiers
avec des bûches électriques avec de
vrais pistes cyclables et je suis pour
une consultation de la population je
mettrai un beau dossier on le mettra sur
la table chacun y sera associé ça mérite
qu'on fasse des études sérieuses des
comparaisons et ensemble on prendra la
décision décider en concertation avec la
population c'est également ce que
souhaiterait Guillaume Pelletier
candidat divers droites qui proposerait
un référendum afin de mieux saisir la
position des tours enjaux sur ce dossier
mais quoi qu'il en soit pour lui le
tramway n'est pas la meilleure solution
pour la ville de Tours je souhaite
proposer des alternatives développer
considérablement par exemple
l'utilisation du vélo en créant des
bornes libre-services de location de
vélo vélo pour tous dans tous les
quartiers de la ville je souhaite autre
exemple développer des pistes cyclables
en site propre ou encore
couper le dispositif Autolib
c'est-à-dire une cinquantaine de
voitures en libre-service des véhicules
propres pour les petits et moyens
transports dans l'agglomération pour
tous les tours en jeu enfin chez les
Verts il s'agit tout d'abord de
dynamiser la pratique du vélo pour les
déplacements quotidiens et d'autres
parts d'améliorer les services de
transport en commun pour cela bien sûr
le tramway et ce sur plusieurs lignes
faut un plan ambitieux de de transport
collectif il faut une offre alternative
à la voiture
enfin en tout cas déplacement individuel
c'est-à-dire la voiture à l'automobile
et bien sûr ça passe par deux lignes de
tramway alors simples Nord-Sud est-ouest
et qui desservent les grands équipements
c'est-à-dire qui desservent égal les
quartiers d'habitat social et les et les
et les cliniques et les hôpitaux
ce que le projet actuel imaginé par Jean
Germain représenterait un investissement
de 290 millions d'euros un financement
assuré par le syndicat intercommunal des
transports en commun de l'agglomération
et par les subventions de l'état de la
région et du département